hoy vamos a hablar del tema que todos
estamos esperando el gasto público en la
unión europea tras el coronavirus
y no os vayáis todavía tú no no te
quedes dormido
ya lo sé a hablar de los presupuestos
generales de la unión europea aparece en
principio más aburrido que un solo de
triángulo pero estamos hablando de una
de las mayores operaciones de gasto
público de la historia durante los
próximos siete años europa va a gastarse
más de dos billones de euros y si digo
billones en castellano en inglés sería
trillions y diréis pero de dónde saldrá
todo ese dinero pues si veis este vídeo
desde cualquier país de la unión europea
ya os lo podéis imaginar de vuestro
bolsillo y probablemente si vivís fuera
de la unión europea también porque pues
luego lo vamos a ver pero lo cierto es
que hablamos de uno de los temas más
importantes de este momento un tema que
va a tener consecuencias muy profundas
en nuestras vidas es decir que puede
parecer aburrido pero creedme que os
debería interesar así que las preguntas
que nos hacemos son porque la unión
europea quiere gastar tanto dinero
precisamente en este momento en el que
estamos saliendo de la crisis del
coronavirus hacia dónde irá a parar ese
dinero es una buena idea o tal vez
estamos ante una nueva era de lo que
podríamos llamar capitalismo de
amiguetes hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes os tengo que
recomendar un nuevo canal de youtube en
el que colabora visual política
hablamos de si lo hubiera sabido el
nuevo canal de actualidad financiera
creado por mutuactivos en este canal
vais a descubrir todas las tendencias
más importantes que mueven las finanzas
puede ser rentable invertir en empresas
sostenibles cómo podemos utilizar la
bolsa para proteger nuestros ahorros de
la inflación cuánta pensión vamos a
cobrar todas estas son preguntas a las
que se responden en este canal todo ello
sin clic byte sin sensacionalismo y con
muchísimo rigor os dejo el link en la
descripción y ahora sí vamos a ver un
poco de historia
la receta keynesiana
ya sé lo que os estaréis preguntando
todos porque la unión europea quiere
sacar tantísimos programas de gasto
justo en este momento porque ahora en
realidad la unión europea no está sola
en esto eeuu también ha dicho que va a
subir el gasto público y muchos otros
países van a hacer lo mismo y os
preguntaréis por qué vale que estamos en
una situación única acabamos de pasar
por toda una pandemia que ha dejado la
economía temblando es más en realidad a
estas alturas ni siquiera estamos
seguros de haber terminado del todo con
la pandemia del nuevo sars coronavirus 2
pero qué tiene que ver una crisis
económica con la necesidad de aumentar
el gasto público la respuesta está en
este señor que veis en la foto
os presento a john maynard keynes uno de
los economistas más influyentes de la
historia podríamos decir que el lord
came fue el padre de la socialdemocracia
moderna aunque en realidad su doctrina
económica ha influido a partidos de todo
el espectro político ha influido y sigue
influyendo por ellos que aunque los
games falleciera en el año 1945 todavía
hoy en día seguimos aplicando algunas de
sus recetas al pie de la letra
y diréis pero que defendía este voy a
enseñar pues que james entendía que la
economía es una rueda que no puede
frenarse en su opinión las crisis
económicas son malas porque los
ciudadanos y el resto de actores
económicos de repente dejan de consumir
y esto frena la actividad conclusión la
mejor forma de salir de una crisis según
kane es que siga la fiesta volver a
activar el consumo como sea y las
empresas privadas y los ciudadanos ya no
pueden consumir entonces lo ideal es que
lo haga el estado a fin de cuentas el
estado siempre puede endeudarse subir
los impuestos o incluso imprimir su
propio dinero por supuesto que todas
estas decisiones tienen consecuencias
pero por poder puede de esta forma la
teoría keynesiana dice a grosso modo
esto es un resumen que en épocas de
recesión el estado tiene que gastar eso
generaría nuevos puestos de trabajo que
a su vez se traducirían en gente con dyn
en el bolsillo para comprar cosas a
empresas privadas de repente el dinero
vuelve a moverse y la economía sale del
atolladero
pero no sólo eso hay otra ventaja en
esta teoría las empresas privadas
invierten dinero en lo que es rentable y
eso técnicamente no siempre es bueno
para lo que llamamos el bien común sin
embargo el estado puede decidir gastar
en cosas buenas para todos cosas como
ciencia innovación servicios públicos
quién puede estar en contra de todo esto
sí ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
en principio las recetas keynesianas
podrían parecer la solución final a
todos los grandes problemas económicos
ni comunismo ni libre mercado
keynesianismo el maridaje perfecto entre
empresas y estados verdad como os podéis
imaginar hay un problema y para que lo
entendamos mejor vamos a verlo con un
ejemplo españa año 2009
como ya sabéis españa fue uno de los
países más afectados por la gran crisis
financiera de 2008 en menos de dos años
la tasa de desempleo se duplicó y en
esos momentos tan duros el por entonces
presidente del gobierno josé luís
rodríguez zapatero hizo el anuncio más
importante de su carrera en esto
consiste el plan español de estímulo de
la economía y el empleo que desde hoy
vamos a llamar plan y si mis queridos
amigos de visual política hablamos del
famoso plan y en pocos años españa se
gastó entre 12.000 y 50.000 millones de
euros y sí ya lo sé la horquilla es muy
grande pero es que aún hoy en día es
difícil calcular cuál fue el monto total
de este plan y diréis eso es mucho o
poco dinero pues por comparar la
recaudación de impuestos de españa ese
mismo año en 2009 fue de 198 mil
millones de euros es decir que si de
repente españa aumentó su partida de
gasto público como si no hubiera mañana
y diréis pero simple de repente el
gobierno se dedicó a gastar dinero así
porque sí
sí no
pues por ridículo que suene si
básicamente durante los años del plan en
todas las ciudades españolas
repavimentaron sus calles renovaron el
mobiliario urbano y pusieron una
maravillosa estatua de arte moderno en
cada rotonda pensar que no existía
ningún objetivo concreto es decir esto
no era un plan para que se renovar los
hospitales porque se habían quedado
obsoletos tampoco se intentaba mejorar
no se las infraestructuras porque fuera
necesario no el objetivo en sí mismo era
generar gasto público para crear nuevos
puestos de trabajo con los que
resucitaron una economía con bastantes
problemas así que cualquier proyecto por
ridículo que fuera era susceptible de
estar financiado no me creéis pues aquí
os voy a dar una sanción
el spa público de la capital lleva año y
medio cerrado la instalación construida
con fondos del plan e y con un
presupuesto de
959 mil euros no llegó a ser inaugurada
ella sé lo qué pensaréis muchos bueno y
dónde está el problema vale un
ayuntamiento se gasta casi un millón de
euros en construir un spa que resulta
que nadie termina usando pero que
importa si el estado puede endeudarse
hasta el infinito y más allá pues si
tenéis razón los estados pueden pedir
más dinero prestado que las familias o
las empresas todo esto es cierto hasta
cierto punto
gracias
españa emitió bonos de deuda como si no
hubiera mañana para pagar todo este
gasto y mientras tanto los medios
españoles estaban demasiado ocupados
discutiendo sobre ello
no recuerdo los temas de moda en ese
momento pero lo cierto es que los
inversores internacionales
esos que estaban prestando dinero a
españa cada vez se fiaban menos de que
el estado español pudiera devolver lo
prestado y aquí es donde viene la cara b
de la deuda qué pasa cuando los
inversores no se fían de ti pues pasa
exactamente esto moody's pone la deuda
española a un nivel por encima del bono
basura en otras palabras españa debía
tanto dinero que era difícil devolverlo
y como nadie se fiaba de españa los
inversores pedían intereses más altos
para compensar todo ese riesgo para que
os hagáis una idea hubo años donde solo
el pago de los intereses de la deuda
suponía la segunda partida de gasto más
grande de todos los presupuestos sólo
por delante de las pensiones y entonces
es cuando los medios de comunicación
dejaron de preocuparse por todos esos
temas de los que ya ni me acuerdo y
empezaron a plantearse hasta qué punto
españa
en bancarrota como español que soy que
ha vivido esa crisis creedme se os digo
que no queréis vivir una crisis parecida
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
pues sé que nos has dado un ejemplo muy
concreto españa es un ejemplo de gasto
público mal ejecutado probablemente los
políticos españoles sean corruptos o
simplemente no hayan consultado a los
expertos adecuados verdad en este caso
sin embargo estamos hablando de la unión
europea en este caso el gasto público va
a estar supervisado por las mentes más
brillantes de europa gente súper lista
que sabe exactamente dónde y cómo gastar
esos 2 billones de euros de forma
eficiente no se trata de gastar por
gastar verdad pues ahora mismo lo vamos
a ver
el manguerazo europeo
antes de seguir tenemos que hacer un
pequeño apunte a diferencia de la mayor
parte de los estados los presupuestos de
la unión europea se aprueban para los
próximos 7 años es decir que los
presupuestos que se han aprobado ahora
cubren desde el año 2020 hasta el año
2027 pues bien estos presupuestos que se
acaban de aprobar se pueden dividir en
tres partidas por un lado está el
presupuesto ordinario que asciende a 1,1
billones de euros
tenemos el mecanismo sur que es donde se
dan las ayudas a los negocios que más
han sufrido durante las cuarentenas y
finalmente está la madre de todo este
nuevo plan de gasto público el llamado
next generation
esta partida suponen más de 750 mil
millones de euros y esta es la gran
apuesta de la unión europea y en este
caso sí que hay una idea detrás de todo
este programa de gasto esa idea es nada
más y nada menos que convertir a europa
en el lugar más ecológico digital
holístico y 2.0 del mundo lo que se
traduce en lo que podríamos llamar el
gran banquero europeo el mayor programa
de gasto público de la historia de la
unión europea más de 2 billones de euros
que se van a gastar en los próximos
siete años y si hablamos de nuevo de
millones en castellano es decir que en
inglés sería trillions
para que os hagáis una idea esto es casi
siete veces lo que costó el rescate
total de la economía griega pero en este
caso se acaba de aprobar sin que
prácticamente nadie haya puesto el más
mínimo pero y diréis pero cómo se va a
pagar todo esto pues creo que ya os
podéis imaginar la respuesta el
parlamento europeo votan nuevos
impuestos en la unión europea para
devolver los préstamos de la
recuperación y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando muchos de verdad es suficiente
con crear estos nuevos impuestos para
financiar todo este gasto evidentemente
no porque pues por que europa necesita
dinero y lo necesita ya y qué hacen los
estados cuando necesitan dinero rápido
pues creo que también os podéis imaginar
la respuesta
la unión europea emite el mayor bono de
un solo tramo para financiar la
recuperación tras la crisis la unión
europea envía un fuerte mensaje con su
bono inaugural bernstein haréis jong joo
para apoyar una recuperación verde
digital y responsable exacto de repente
lo que antes era un tema tabú en la
unión europea hoy es una realidad
los eurobonos y diréis pero porque los
eurobonos eran un tema tabú en la unión
europea en visual político sacamos un
vídeo sobre este tema hace un año tenéis
el enlace en la descripción pero en
resumen el problema con los eurobonos es
que liberan a los estados miembros de la
responsabilidad de pagar las deudas de
sus economías dicho de otra forma que
los países con baja calificación
crediticia como españa o grecia se
apoyan en los países más fiables de
europa como alemania o países bajos todo
esto podría ser una buena idea si los
presupuestos europeos se ejecutarán
desde bruselas pero es que la realidad
es muy distinta porque en realidad la
unión europea solo pone el dinero pero
quienes deciden dónde se gasta son
justamente los países miembros y os
preguntaréis pero como se está
repartiendo este dinero es un reparto a
partes iguales va por una cuestión de
población pues nada de eso atentos a
esta gráfica
aquí podéis ver como españa es el
ganador indiscutible en estos
presupuestos se lleva más del 15 por
ciento de todo ese manguerazo europeo y
no la mayor parte de ese dinero no se va
a gestionar desde bruselas sino desde
madrid el funcionamiento es el siguiente
los países miembros en este caso españa
presentan lo que llaman un plan de gasto
a bruselas bruselas lo aprueba y paga
todas las facturas dicho de otra forma
que los políticos nacionales pueden
colgarse la medalla de gastar dinero a
manos llenas mientras cargan con el
muerto de la deuda y los impuestos a la
unión europea
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
no puede ser tan sencillo a ver si
hablamos de la unión europea el lugar
donde se juntan las mentes más
brillantes de la política mundial seguro
que hay un montón de controles para
evitar que el dinero termine donde no
debe verdad seguro que en bruselas no
van a permitir un fracaso absoluto como
fue el plan en españa pues tenéis razón
en parte la unión europea quiere
garantizar que todos los países miembros
tengan estado de derecho y mecanismos de
lucha contra la corrupción y todo eso
explica noticias cómo está la unión
europea está lista para aprobar el plan
de recuperación de polonia en noviembre
y varsovia acepta algunos compromisos
para recuperar la seguridad jurídica
muchos pensaréis que esta es la prueba
definitiva de que en bruselas saben
gastar el dinero público pero la
pregunta es de verdad son suficientes
estos mecanismos de control pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver y lo vamos a ver
con el país que más dinero se va a
llevar de todos estos presupuestos
atentos
spain is diferent o tal vez no
como hemos dicho españa es el mayor
beneficiado de estos presupuestos
europeos al menos de la partida next
generation
y también ha sido uno de los primeros
países en presentar su plan de gasto el
plan españa puede indica como el
gobierno de españa va a gastar los más
de 140 mil millones de euros que le van
a llegar de europa podéis consultarlo en
su página web que os dejo la descripción
el problema en el momento en el que
hacemos este vídeo solo se pueden ver
unos pocos proyectos de gasto y diréis
pero y qué pasa con los demás
pues no se sabe dicho de otra forma que
la unión europea ha aprobado el plan de
gasto de españa sin que a duras penas se
haya hecho público por supuesto se puede
consultar pero es mucho más complicado
que entrando en la página web y si esto
en sí mismo es una falta absoluta de
transparencia además es una oportunidad
de oro para las grandes consultoras como
kpmg atentos
kpmg revoluciona el asesoramiento en
fondos europeos kpmg en españa y local
europe han firmado una alianza para
ofrecer una solución integral de
servicios de consultoría sobre fondos
europeos junto a una herramienta
tecnológica exclusiva que facilita la
identificación de los proyectos
concretos que pueden ser elegibles para
el acceso a las ayudas exacto las
grandes consultoras ya se han puesto
manos a la obra para asesorar sobre cómo
echar mano de ese man grafo europeo y
quién puede contratar los servicios de
kpmg pues cree en mí hablamos de
servicios caros servicios que podríamos
decir que sólo están disponibles para
las grandes empresas pero esperad porque
no hemos visto nada
de entre los proyectos que sí se han
hecho públicos hay dos especialmente
llamativos uno es la rehabilitación de
edificios públicos es decir que si el
plan y sirvió para repavimentar todas
las calles de españa el plan e-ii va a
servir para rehabilitar los edificios
públicos algo que como todo el mundo
sabe es fundamental para la lucha contra
el cambio climático y la transformación
económica verdad pero esperad porque
todavía hay más otro de los planes que
ha propuesto españa es
la creación de un hub audiovisual es
decir españa se va a gastar la friolera
de 200 millones de euros en subvenciones
para hacer series de televisión y
videojuegos y ahora como todo tiene que
ser ecológico digital holístico y 2.0
este proyecto incluye perlas como es la
comisión trabajará en una guía de
mejores prácticas para la producción
ecológica y la prestación de servicios
el enfoque será gradual con el objetivo
de crear conciencia y empujar a la
industria a comenzar a implementar
soluciones más sostenibles
'españa hub audiovisual de europa página
y cómo se pueden producir películas
videojuegos y series de televisión de
forma ecológica y sostenible
pues no lo sé pero existe todo un
informe sobre cómo
ecologizar la producción audiovisual
m
a estas alturas muchos estaréis
preguntando a quién se le ha ocurrido
este proyecto en quien medida la
producción de series de televisión y de
videojuegos sirve para esa
transformación ecológica digital
holística y 2.0 que tanto necesita
europa pues los que veáis este vídeo
desde españa ya os podréis imaginar
quién está detrás de todo esto mediapro
busca en versión millonaria para su
propio jada audiovisual según asegura
expansión el grupo ha iniciado la
búsqueda de capital unos 500 millones de
euros para crear un nuevo hub
audiovisual en españa para los que no
conozcáis a mediapro se trata de una
productora de cine y televisión con
lazos muy conocidos con los partidos que
ahora están en el gobierno su presidente
es este señor que veis en pantalla que
se llama jaume roures y mediapro está al
borde de la bancarrota hecho han pedido
varias veces un rescate al gobierno
dicho de otra forma que podríamos decir
que este proyecto del hub o divisor de
europa presuntamente podría llegar a
tener nombre y apellidos y esperad un
momento porque podría no ser el único
ejemplo
atentos
un juez desbloquea el rescate de plus
ultra' al no apreciar por ahora ningún
delito la aerolínea recibirá a los 34
millones de euros que tiene pendientes
para poder seguir operando en este caso
hablamos del rescate de una aerolínea
que opera cuatro vuelos a la semana
prácticamente nadie en españa sabía de
su existencia hasta hace unos pocos
meses los dueños de estar o líneas son
venezolanos y también podrían tener
ciertas conexiones con algunos miembros
o ex miembros del gobierno o de los
partidos del gobierno así que españa no
ha dudado ni un momento en rescatar les
por supuesto este rescate puede ser
perfectamente legal igual que el
proyecto del hub audiovisual a fin de
cuentas en tiempos de coronavirus y han
rescatado a muchas otras empresas la
pregunta es
de verdad esta es una empresa
estratégica a la que había que rescatar
y se rescata plus ultra' porque no se
debería rescatar a cualquier otra
empresa que esté en apuros y diréis pero
vamos a ver fonseca no puede ser tan
simple seguro que alguien en bruselas se
encarga de asegurar que no hay
corrupción ni capitalismo de amiguetes a
la hora de gastar el dinero y si tenéis
razón hay un órgano europeo encargado de
controlar el dinero público la fiscalía
anticorrupción el problema el problema
es que están saturados
pensadlo así más gasto público significa
muchos más proyectos que investigar
cuántos más proyectos que investigar
pues veréis alguna una estimación de la
propia comisión europea hablamos de una
carga de trabajo nueve veces más grande
de lo normal sin embargo a duras penas
se ha incrementado la plantilla de
investigadores es decir que europa se va
a gastar muchísimo dinero en un montón
de cosas menos en contratar a gente para
controlar todo ese gasto así que ahora
la pregunta es para vosotros de verdad
este manguerazo europeo va a servir para
que europa se vuelva más ecológica
sostenible digital holística y 2.0 o en
realidad estamos ante una nueva era de
capitalismo de amiguetes qué impacto va
a tener todo esto en nuestro bolsillo
volveremos a ver una nueva crisis de la
deuda en europa podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis que aquí en visual
politics sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribirse a este canal
y darle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones
tampoco olvidéis visitar si lo hubiera
sabido ese canal en el que colabora
activamente visual político si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo
y hasta pronto